welcome to this video playing step by
step from Bulgaria and I am that I've
played really really often what you do
here probably form okay yeah all that
looks very strange to me isn't white
just losing ton of time here with his
pieces okay how to play him yeah I mean
don't have any problems here but how to
how to exploit this as best as possible
yeah maybe maybe keep it simple with
Bishop t6
yeah guess Knight takes pawn takes is an
is an ugly pawn structure this is quite
okay if I get in Queenie 5 and so okay
but after this what happens if I go if I
go Queen f6 here for example I can also
take very strange I take yeah well this
this looks this really looks the most
problematic for white
Queen B 2 and Knight c3 and always could
be to us could not be five so i go here
and now d 4 is interesting not take and
deform and take and d for my TV forum
yeah let's go let's go d for him just
keeping keeping in the night down okay
should I go see five yeah I want i'm
going to make sure that the night stays
there
okay there's nothing very active that I
can do right I guess so
yeah I have this is active active
looking pieces but it's not so clear
what they what they actually do opponent
the night if I take take hu here and you
will take deform
maybe I should support this with the ruh
cannot allow the trades this is maybe
maybe the way to go
yeah the Eric I can maybe activate on
the egg farm that's a tense interesting
position really ok trying to to play
against the sea por now with rook c8
Quincy five and this is just weakening
Rican my jam um Roxy eight now we don't
think that f4 is helpful for him just
weakens a ton of squares
um yeah I can send it back though or not
really the what is strange i don't
understand any move by my opponent this
is always always problematic if you feel
like okay either the guys playing
playing totally totally bad or you don't
understand anything they're only those
two options okay i can take this now
right it's going to f3 that nor what is
he doing maybe at this first is better i
can take you for now now cannot because
of 92 why this was lucky i could have
taken see for him anyway but I thought
that maybe queena 3 was so some some
sort of counter play okay now i'm taking
this okay i can even take b5 don't see
why not
time warning
yeah f5 is a good point to get I have h
4 and possibly Nigeria with a meeting
net that's very nice and it's already a
ton of extra points
and I can also take a three minutes
that's probably easier white resigns
yeah I was a weird game really weird
game from from start from start to
finish you hear they then there is not
much happening I thought he should just
just play 92 or D for whatever yeah it's
it's it's a bit it's a bit tricky now I
mean how to see how does he play now the
the weakness on c3 is a problem he
cannot move the night and something like
that for example it's also not very
comfortable hey this is of course
playable for white but it's not much fun
it's just a bit better for black yeah
this looks very nice yeah Queen B to
Isis is probably also good but I
couldn't really couldn't really
calculated and one they didn't want to
fall too much behind on the clock I've
lost the number of games of time against
the guy already this is this is probably
good young because here like it some is
up material at the end okay and this is
just just I'm very unclear we have to
tough to evaluate so yeah interesting i
don't know i liked rope the eight
keeping this on the board yeah here for
example f4 is an interesting move which
would yeah this isn't a good for white
this means that Ruby aid was bad air
force am getting my bishop in trouble
intending this stuff hmm that's very bad
really that's it's almost winning for
whiter
okay so he should do F for them and now
it's now it's a bit a bit late when he
when he went for this gather compass
already giving me more than one pawn
simply because of the sea pawn yeah this
is getting worse and worse minus for now
yeah okay here that's just picking up
the pieces after after that I was still
ahead overlooked initially that this is
of course check we had peace I was a bit
afraid here after f5 thought that here
he might have something like that if I
go g5 now we can take this this scared
me a bit but even this seems to be
winning yeah nothing that you want to
try out though okay thanks for watching